you go to durham north carolina the
durham public school system has half a
dozen schools
they are they close their schools
schools are not reopening okay so
instead what they're doing it's all
online learning but they are operating
six
learning centers and the learning
centers
are going to allow kids to come in and
you know with their laptops and do the
online learning
do you know where the learning centers
are
the learning centers at prison what no
well county prison sort of
we are in a reality war i think that's
what you know we call it the culture war
but i think it's starting to become the
reality war
that seems to me where we're at and the
issue that you have
i don't know if the first one of these
happened before you went off the grid
but you had an image of an msnbc
reporter standing in front of a burning
oh ali velshi
yes yeah yeah alibell she's standing in
front of the thing there's nothing to
see here it's mostly peaceful
uh dude there's a building exploding on
fire yeah we got another one on cnn
about a week ago we got another it was
the same thing it was like you could
have just swapped the reporters it was
the exact same thing
same story but do you see why they can't
stop they can't stop because they're in
so deep that to stop to stop that wheel
that we were talking about before
they would have to they'd they'd have to
commit harry carey yeah you know what i
mean they'd have to just impale
themselves on their own swords
that would be the only way they would
have to say yes we have
been [ __ ] artists epic
[ __ ] artists decades speaking of
[ __ ] arts like is the new york times
still a newspaper or did that thing wrap
up
it was i mean it was crumbling i don't
think it's been a newspaper they had
announced they weren't going to do news
anymore they were going to run it by
like a seventh grader
so yeah the trans seventh grader was
gonna be able to correct things
something like that yeah all of the
editors of the new york times now have
to be trans seventh graders and you
you have to trans all the kids well
actually yeah so the new york times
is still whatever it is i'm not gonna
say it's a newspaper but it's still
whatever it is
but on on the school front there is some
really weird stuff going on
so oh right are schools opening like
what's going on there do we have schools
anymore so
let's look at new york obviously giant
school system i come from the new york
public schools you come from as dwelling
right so new york has
no plan to reopen restaurants nope no
plan
he said maybe june of next year they
just don't know
they're just shooting from the hip
however
schools are going to be back in session
it was just today was delayed so now
they're going to push it was supposed to
already start wait so schools are not
starting in new york next well i guess
it would be today it would be or
today and they've they have delayed it
but they they didn't they got a lot of
flack for saying the schools have to
reopen
and no one understood why are the
schools it made perfect sense to me
you still want to indoctrinate the kids
you've still placed a warehouse
to push the indoctrination you know it
got so
weird that in outside of new york you go
to
durham north carolina the durham public
school system has
half a dozen schools they are they close
their schools schools are not reopening
okay
so instead what they're doing it's all
online learning but they
are operating six learning centers
and the learning centers are going to
allow kids to come in
and you know with their laptops and do
the online learning
do you know where the learning centers
are
the learning centers at prison what no
well county prison sort of the learning
centers
are in the schools which are closed
no but it gets better dave it gets
better
i know it's hard because i'm just
getting back on the grid so maybe my
english isn't maybe
what you're telling me is durham has
closed the schools totally closed
then they've announced that these
centers will open where the kids can
come with their laptops
to do remote learning to do remote
learning and that is at the schools that
are closed
that's correct yeah makes sense doesn't
it but actually
what you're probably saying is though
the only way that would work
is if the school district charged the
parents more money to come use the
schools which are closed to do the
online learning from the schools that
you can't go to right
that would that would make sense so in
order to use the
remote learning centers at the schools
parents have to pay
140 a week plus 35 registration fee
unless you're a bureaucrat who works for
the government in which case you get a
discount
what's the what's the daily wire uh
policy on the f-word
uh oh it's it's your show my friend yeah
we are at your house
it's [ __ ] insane but again
do you see what i'm saying that there is
nothing too stupid for this movement
yeah there is nothing too insane for
this movement it
it will eat away and rot out ev whatever
institution
allows this stupidity in it will destroy
it yeah and that is
what it sounds like is happening in
durham north carolina
speaking but wait a minute yeah why
would they need more money to do that i
assume everyone's still paying taxes
they didn't tax rebates to the people
they're all still paying taxes so you're
paying the exact amount of taxes that
you always paid for the public schools
the public schools are then closed but
then less people will be there correct
so you'd think you would be able to save
a little money
yeah but then you still got to charge
them so now so in effect only people
with money will be able to send their
kids to those schools
but i thought they're also against
school choice and they're also my brain
is exploding
here's the way to make sense of it has a
government agency
ever said give me less money yeah has
that ever happened
in the history of humanity no they run
literally i mean people don't believe
this but most government agencies run on
a thing where they have to
hit their budget otherwise their budget
gets cut nobody could run a business
like that i can't run my business like
that
where i'm like i have to spend every
freaking cent that i have yeah otherwise
i'm not gonna magically get well because
i'm not giving money i have to earn
money yeah
you know so i so what i do is i save a
certain amount in my business each year
so we can continue to grow
or we might have some problems and then
we can figure out that's
that's completely foreign yeah that's
completely foreign to a government an
economic genius over here i know you are
and you know actually
speaking of kind of naughty words going
blue yeah i have to read you there is a
song
that is i'll just close your ears bust
out your glasses like i wish excuse me
sir
now that we're going blue so there's a
new song that's taken over the world
and when i say taking over the world i
mean like this is the story
okay this is like the story yeah so
i don't even know you know i don't go
blue on my show yeah i don't know
clean clean cut i don't wear socks in my
loafers you know i try to be
i can't say the name of this of this
song without going blue
would it be better and you're hosting
right now so i want you to do what you
think is right would it be better if
if i just read it straight i would feel
much better if you
so the song is called whap okay
right it's like it's by cardi yeah w.a.p
okay it's by cardi b and this one i mean
this is like
now the the anthem the feminist anthem
right and cardi b
i'm not totally sure who she is but i
know she was like fighting with people
right before i went yes
she she supported bernie sanders
i think she and i think that's racist
for you to say that but yes she does
have long skills
so here's so this is this song has just
taken over everyone's this is everyone's
taken over
so i'll just i guess i'll just read a
little yeah [ __ ] in this house
there's some [ __ ] in this house
there's some [ __ ] in this house
there's some [ __ ] in this house hole
up i said certified
freak seven days a week wet ass [ __ ]
make that pull out game weak
that's good and then the chorus yeah
yeah yeah
yeah you [ __ ] with some sweet ass
[ __ ]
bring a bucket and mop for this [ __ ]
mop
for this oh bring a bucket and mop for
this
you got to mop up give me everything you
got for this wet
ass [ __ ] uh i'm gonna not do the next
paragraph because that's where they'll
come for me
yeah this is the if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell